thanks a lot for uh for joining me today
my name is Ahmed a technology platform
manager in Telstra Health
um I look after
centralized technology platform
including API management and this was my
journey also in in the last couple of
roles one of them is in AGL energy where
I was looking after the API platform
team so we do a lot in the API space
API programs and a lot of what I do in
the day-to-day is related to security so
happy to share some of that kind of
practical
environments that I have came through in
my experience
uh I'm sure you all know what was top 10
now like there's no good security talk
unless it actually brings that slide
some somehow so um
this would be the base of uh of my talk
basically what we are trying to do is to
stand uh start from those common most
critical security risks that is
published by Security Experts and trying
to see how an API platform have an API
Gateway can help mitigate some of these
risks
[Music]
could be what is the difference between
API management and API Gateway
so the the answer is simple API
management is is a product or a system
that has couple of two main components
API and Gateway and this is actually
towards the uh the the services
it's kind of linking that mobile web
application to the service at the top
um
and an API developer portal so the
developer portal is more towards people
not services and what does that mean
um while the API Gateway
has features like representation caching
and security it's protecting your your
apis and services the developer portal
is making your apis available
discoverable
securely uh security you you actually
your developers those developers could
be in your organization it could be in a
partner organization
or it could be external developers just
outside of
of your organization or your partner
organization as well like in the
community so it's essential to make sure
your API strategy is is actually serving
those three
actors and my recommendation is always
to use the same same system the same
program for both internal and external
and partner organizations it's one of
these things that it's really hard if
you have three different API programs in
your organization right
so the first thing I want to talk about
is authorization right
um
even if you haven't actually written any
security code before or even if you
haven't actually
work on Azure API management before I
want you to look at this XML declarative
syntax and after a while raise your hand
if you can understand what it's doing
please
right couple all right three
four
four
six
all right
okay people are still coming seven eight
right
that's really good so like even though
um we have people in the room that might
not have used that technology before
they can actually understand that
declarative code what that code is doing
is simply
um protecting an API by making sure it's
the request is actually authorized
before it reach the API backend service
right how that is important is important
because why in order to succeed in an
API program visibility is really
important so to be able to have a single
source of truths where all of your like
API Architects and developers and
security team they don't have to go
through tons of code to find out how
your API is secured is really important
so it's really important to have your
first line of defense right and
declarative and easily understood by all
of your organizations so I work in
organizations where there is dot net
there's Java there's python there's all
sort of Technologies
but the information about security how
apis are secured is essential and so
when you have this when you have this
visibility it actually helps a lot so
make sure to use your API Gateway to be
the first line of defense that is
related to authorizations this can be
also I hope all is too but you also have
so many ways to to protect your apis and
API gateways tend to have that
capability so the only the other benefit
that this gives you is decoupling
between your front-end authorization and
your backend authorization so often you
will find a New Journey that you have
very weak Legacy systems that let's say
they have basic authentication or API
keys and you don't want to bubble that
to the client because of all the
security issues you want to hide that in
the in your network perimeter and offer
a facade on top of that because you
can't touch it we have seen always seen
that in Enterprises so that actually
gave you that capability as well
great simple architecture I promise this
would be the only kind of architecture
diagram you would see today and
maybe one of the things here is the
um
let me just get the pointer
right so you see a couple of actors here
the public actor which is coming through
the internet and a private actor which
is this is your staff members these are
your employees going through a VPN going
into your your network it's important
for your API strategy to save both at
the same time and the advice here is to
always deploy your API Gateway in a
private Network right and that's a
private Network on Azure so you have
your um you have your web first that's
the that's your o wasp kind of weft
Appliance and then you have your API
Gateway
that is executing API policies and then
you have your other private
infrastructure and that either in the
v-net or in a peered v-net using a hop
and spoke model which is pretty common
architecture and then this can also go
outside of the private network if we you
want to so my advice is don't when you
deploy an API Gateway make sure it's
deployed privately because that would
save you a lot of
pain after that if you started publicly
and now you have the requirement to make
it private
the other advice is make sure your your
backend system is not just putting
something behind an API Gateway you have
to block access
of everything else except the API
Gateway so by making that making sure
that that's in a private Network that's
one step but there are different
ways you can also make sure that
requests are coming from the API Gateway
So based on the technology that you are
using
foreign
let's move to so we're still in the
broken axis uh control that's number one
in the web application or wasp these
things would actually mitigate that risk
one of the things that is always pain to
manage this course if you have ever
worked on a microservice system
you have so many lambdas and Azure
functions and you have a thick client
and you don't actually want to have that
logic
in hundreds of ways in you in your
application so centralize that into the
API Gateway and decouple it from
handling any browser related issues I
don't care if if what calls my backend
is a is is a bro is an application in
the browser or if it's an unattended
Cron job or whatever really it's it's
not something that me interested in
writing code in the in the business API
need to worry about so another thing is
usually when you have applications you
have a lot less applications than what
you have apis and that means you can
actually abstract that course in a
product which is a collection of apis
and apply it to across all of your apis
instead of individually having to secure
each API and we established established
the network security so this is zero
trust we have to establish that the
backend service is making sure that the
requests are coming from your gateway
right
let's move to a cryptographic
cryptographic failures and it's really
um
interesting subject there's lots of
versions out there TLS versions that are
insecure right you want to make sure
your API Gateway is configured correctly
to disable all of the weak ciphers and
insecure TLS versions right so API
Gateway would help a lot in that and
your your kind of day-to-day back-end
Services written in C sharp or dot net
might not have the same capability in
the same in the same strength right so
but the thing that you need to do as
well is to understand
um where your front and TLS handshake
happens right so this is from the from
the Gateway from the front you need to
know is that an edge server is that an
Azure application Gateway is that the
API Gateway you might have different
proxies so you need to ask yourselves
where is the clientele list handshaking
um happen and make sure that that is
secure right don't secure along the line
and forget the front right
but relevant to that
ask your security teams
are we doing stls termination are we
doing termination or are we doing
end-to-end encryption so TLS termination
is something related to
um the the traffic is encrypted up to a
certain point and then decrypt sorry and
then just just fly through unencrypted
so it might be good for performance
reasons right but might not be good for
for governance or for more highly
restrict environments so you have to
understand which model you you do which
model your application is following and
take appropriate decisions based on that
um also telling cryptographic failures
um and also like I'm really a fan of
policy as a code and self-service and so
make sure your API Gateway is configured
and to have policies that instead of
having lengthy review processes where
humans gets involved put your policy
lock it in and that's an example of an
Azure policy that is saying we cannot do
HTTP because it's unencrypted when we
talk from the gateway to a backend
service and we cannot do WS right and
these are unencrypted so it's not
allowed so anyone from any team wants to
provision something like that it's not
they're going to get an error and now
they don't have to go to someone to
review the code anymore because you're
confident that you covered this in a
policy
another great example
is adding security headers and also
removing
informative headers that's a big if you
have ever seen a penetration testing
report
oh yeah you have a server you have a
server a header coming up it's high
right don't wait until you see that
right just go to your API Gateway in the
global policy list all of our
informative headers in your Global
policy as removed right you do it once
you don't do it per API and you just job
done right list all include all of the
security headers that is related to apis
follow OS recommendation there's a page
that has a table of I know 20 or 30
security headers and you do it once and
then you forget about it because it's in
the API and Gateway Global policy and we
already established trust so that would
work pretty well and you will never see
in this penetration testing report again
now a great example of API gateways and
how people can work together right
you know you have seen a lot of swagger
UI right if you work with apis you have
Postman collections yeah Swagger UI you
have a Confluence document you have API
shared shared in email you have Partners
who you might have you might have sent
API Secrets before right this all need
to change right this organization
discovered in one of the
um projects like 13 000 sweater apis
living on the internet that means public
API definitions which means that helping
attackers understand how your API work
right
API and Gateway help you sorry API
management help you not to do that with
the developer portal component which is
allowing for governance of
um acquiring information on your apis so
those people need to sign in you need to
log in with their organization account
to access this valuable information and
even if they are partners and you would
enable them to sign in with their
organization sign-in accounts and gave
them access to your own organization API
information as well so the same same
technique works with the three actors
that I that I was talking about so that
helps mitigate number five security
misconfiguration
another example of security
misconfigurations is you see in the news
thousands of API Keys leaking right so
always
um
really interesting how do we make sure
that a single page app or a mobile
application wants to consume an API
that's using API key or client
credential flow without having to store
the secret in the app right
it's really hard right but API Gateway
would help you solve that problem
there's the pattern here that I'm
describing it's called an API Gateway as
a Secret store and an alternate to that
pattern is API Gateway as an outbound
proxy so you would have lots of
flexibility here to secure and identify
your application right and then you
abstract how you access third-party apis
and using the API Gateway so your API
and Gateway can act as a Secret store
basically what's what's the secret to
twilio we give you the secret and then
you your client can actually now go and
and talk to 12 Year a different maybe
easier way is is also to use it as a
proxy which means your API Gateway is
not just standing as a proxy to your own
apis something that proved to be really
successful for me in the past is your
API and Gateway can also proxy to a
third party apis and what does that mean
is you might have managed Azure managed
identity here for example right doesn't
have to be API key but
that's all what the clients need to
understand and the same identity could
be providing access to both these three
apis an API Gateway have the logic that
oh get the secret for HubSpot get the
secret for Twitter get the secret for
um for twilio all safely stored
encrypted hidden from from the clients
really powerful an example of that is a
new feature that was developed in Azure
API management and that's actually doing
more fancy stuff that previously we had
to write this stuff in the past for
example refresh the token if it's expire
right so it's really really good feature
it would help you in these situations
like if you have a single page app or
maybe an unattended scenario and that
you actually have a person behind that
to to go through the consent
flow so you establish that at the
beginning when you create the connection
and from now on it's the API and Gateway
responsibility to keep your token alive
and use it when it talks to the backend
API
great
um now we are going into more of the API
related risks here this one is lack of
resources and rate limiting so um
basically okay how do we prevent
overloading our services
um and how can the API Gateway help with
that so my advice is always sit Max
request size and a Max file upload limit
also if you have done penetration
testing reports
you will always find okay like we can
just hit you without the limit right if
you are behind an API Gateway that makes
your life easier because you can just
establish that as a one sitting right
not per API that's that's your Baseline
and you can say my Max request body size
is this and my Max file upload site is
that all of apis would be protected by
that
my advice as well is to set a Max
request timeout globally timeout is
important with the size because there
are some attackers that will send you
one kilobyte but they are sending it buy
it by byte over a long period of time
causing connection draining in your
backend system so you have to be aware
of that as well and you have to sit and
request time it as well as I said
sensitive Services can have more
restrict limits but that's your Baseline
in the Gateway
with limits
um you can see this example started to
show some code here really simple way to
to say I only want to get three calls
every 15 seconds based on whatever
subscription ID of the incoming request
is so
um I believe that every API must have a
rate limit right there's no way someone
might say well there's a case where an
API does not need to define a rate limit
what does that mean because there's no
infinite there's no infinite infinite
resources right everything has a limit
so you might say my API can receive 1
billion requests per second right but
that's that's the limit so it's the
large limit but it's the limit so you
can you you have to define a rate limit
for every API and you have to understand
your limits right
and always good to define a global rate
limit as well so like you
um so you can you obviously need to get
this from a local information but it's
good to have a baseline as well at the
global level
as you can see that's another way of um
using your API Gateway using declarative
policies in the outbound section here of
your re of of your request pipeline I'm
just saying store this request in the
cache for 20 seconds that's how you use
it it's as simple as that store this
request for 20 seconds right and and in
the inbound right if another request
come in Within These 20 seconds it will
just do a cache lookup right and you can
you have full control here where do you
want this to to vary by or expire so
each time here I get the different
authorization header right because using
os2 I'm I want this to to be a new
response right because it's local to
that particular user in this case for
example So that obviously help and ease
out the load of your backend Services
because you're requests are not hitting
your backend services at all
so we we moved from rate limiting
resources to excessive data exposure
now one of the great features in any API
Gateway you know I show you the
developer portal and API definitions so
API Gateway understand how your API work
so it understands the schema of all your
requests and responses right so what you
can do is you can say something like
this simple like that allow additional
properties equals false in your
validation right that means if if you
are within a request and someone try to
add new properties to the payload that
you have designed it's going to be
rejected 401 without bothering your your
your engineering teams or or your
developers to actually code that in
their backend Services right and it also
works both ways so this example is
response schema so information exposure
always happens from responses so um you
you build an API you have a let's say a
database like this graph and then
someone changed the code to
return payload from database directly
without checking what to return and what
not and that comes with excessive
information sensitive information that
we don't want to return so the idea here
is to focus on the API contract so we
are doing contract first API development
and or even if you're doing code first
API development someone reviewed and the
API contract uploaded to your API
Gateway or link it to your API Gateway
and the contract have to change first
before an additional property is added
into your response payload
so I always do that kind of validation
to make sure that
um
you kind of not left out with more
information that you need to the last
thing I want to talk about is injection
and always have a web application
firewall and in the in the pause so in
this design this is acting as a web
application firewall so it will have you
all wasp protection against stuff like
SQL injection properties and and all of
that stuff and make sure that the your
system is not accessible Beyond The
Gateway
and these are the that's an example of
the weft rules you will be familiar with
the owas rules all of them make sure
that they are enabled and they are
blocked and make sure that there's
enough sufficient monitoring related to
that in addition to that you might have
the cloud vendor like this is giving me
also protection from malicious Bots that
we are talking about and so make sure
that that's enabled and that will block
bad Bots trying to hit your systems
based on that kind of malicious IP
that's that's it guys thanks thanks a
lot for having me and I'm now ready to
receive any of your questions
[Applause]
thanks
anyone have a question
yep reason
yes
okay you mean in the backing service
obviously yes yes so what okay so the
question is where do we validate do we
validate in the API Gateway and then
walk away and then the API uh the
backend service just assumes that
validation has been done or do we
revalidate let's say if we're talking
about customer consent right do we
revalidate consent in the packing
service or not so yeah okay okay
the best practices validating at the top
level yeah
but what I was saying is
yeah yeah exactly so yep so so yes
um for example I'll give you a an exist
interesting one so the number one
vulnerability or risk in the API top 10
is object level authorization so you
cannot use the API Gateway to protect
you against object level authorization
and risks because it needs the awareness
of the object you need to understand the
scope your IDs you have the your local
DB and if someone passed a different
idea with a different role right the API
Gateway doesn't have that information
right so the API Gateway would validate
that the token has been signed and what
might validate the issuer the audience
might validate the claims but it would
not know if that user have access to
that entity or not right so you still
need to re-validate that in the API
somehow a good example in that is a
token exchange flow so token exchange
flow for example the API Gateway would
receive a token and as a middleman but
also pass the token
um to the back-end service and the
backend service now would understand
that the tokens coming from the API
Gateway but I still can do further
checks and look do DB lookups and and
even validate the signature of the token
again the code so it's really up to up
to the security policies but I would
advise that no it's not just the APA
Gateway it's not we're not trying to
build the centralized authorization
management the local checks still has to
be there the API Gateway is just your
first line of defense yeah
yeah
yep
thank you
whoa great question I do recommend end
to end encryption right
um
it's not until you really really really
have a strong performance if you're if
you want to save like billions of
requests per second and your
infrastructure is struggling with the
end to end right first I would say
minimize number of proxies if you can
right for example if you can use Azure
front door as a as an edge server and
application Gateway at the same time
then use it so you minimize number of
proxies uh but and but if that didn't
work then go for don't go for a TLS
termination but end-to-end encryption is
my advice yeah
yep
data yeah
um no because because the backend
service has to publish its API
definition somehow so the team that's
building the API has to say these are my
API definitions so from that the API
Gateway knows exactly the schema of your
payloads whether it's request or
response and it can use that for
validation and making sure there's no
additional properties coming in or out
yeah
all right thanks a lot thank you thanks
for having me
[Music]